Trascrizione: giulia tornabene
Revisore: Chiara Polesinanti
Buon pomeriggio.
L’introduzione è stata più che sufficiente
per capire da dove vengo.
Io sono un medico --
parte dei miei laboratori
sono a un passo da qua,
per cui questo mi dà ulteriori emozioni --
e vi voglio parlare di telefoni cellulari.
Qualcuno dirà: “Ma come mai Dominici
si mette a parlare di telefoni?”
Perché un anno fa ho incontrato
un gruppo di persone
e mi chiesero:
“Ma tu cosa cosa fai esattamente?”
“Mi occupo, sviluppo Terapie Cellulari.”
E questi mi dicevano:
“Scusa ma col cellulare
come fai a curare le persone?”
La cosa ovviamente mi fece ridere,
ma mi diede molto da pensare.
Per cui oggi pomeriggio
voglio parlare con voi
di quello che è stato
lo sviluppo della telefonia cellulare
e di quello che è attualmente
lo sviluppo delle terapie cellulari.
E quindi mi sono permesso
di andare un po’ a frugare su internet
e cercare di capire
come è stata questa cosa.
Non sono un ingegnere
delle telecomunicazioni,
ma questo è stato
il primo telefono cellulare
che chiamarono trasportabile.
Ovviamente mi viene un po’ da ridere
perché è l’unica differenza
tra una cabina SIP e questo
è che questo pesava 5 chili circa,
l’autonomia era di 30 minuti
e la cabina SIP era arancione
o rossa, a seconda dei punti di vista,
per cui è chiaro che fu una rivoluzione.
Fu una rivoluzione degli anni ’80,
ma cosa aveva di buono?
Sì, che si poteva portare in giro,
ma che aveva un’autonomia
veramente molto limitata, 30 minuti,
e senza in realtà la rete.
Ma quali sono stati i pionieri
delle terapie cellulari?
Vi porto a San Pietroburgo,
in Unione Sovietica.
Questi tre personaggi,
che sembrano cucinare un soufflé,
in realtà fanno una delle scoperte
più importanti della medicina:
scoprono che nel sangue periferico
dei soggetti sani
possiamo trovare delle cellule,
che chiamiamo linfociti,
che ci difendono dalle infezioni,
che se portati in laboratorio
possono proliferare, possono crescere.
Questa è una scoperta che ha cambiato
grandemente la storia dell’immunologia
e della medicina in generale.
Ma vediamo cosa è accaduto
nella nostra telefonia cellulare.
Questo...
Ci portiamo negli anni ’80.
Questo è un telefono, chiamiamolo piccolo,
pesava 800 grammi,
aveva una tecnologia analogica
aveva un display quantomeno ridicolo,
delle reti molto scarse.
Era sicuramente rivoluzionario,
ma era assolutamente insicuro,
ovvero chiunque poteva clonare quel numero
e utilizzarlo a proprio scopo.
Ma è stata a sua volta una rivoluzione.
E che altre rivoluzioni possiamo trovare
all’interno delle terapie cellulari?
Chi altro ha fatto cose simili?
Qui vi porto negli Stati Uniti, a Seattle.
Siamo nel 1957 e questi ricercatori,
in particolare questo signore
a capo tavola,
con un gruppo di personaggi che sembrano
essere usciti dai telefilm CHiPs --
non so se vi ricordate --
ecco questi personaggi hanno cambiato
la storia della medicina,
perché hanno inventato il modo
di trapiantare quelle stesse cellule,
che quel russo che si chiamava Maximow
aveva identificato nel 1915.
Quindi si tratta di un modo per curare
i pazienti, in questo caso con leucemia,
partendo da che cosa:
da sangue ottenuto
non tanto dal sangue periferico
ma dal sangue
che veniva dal midollo osseo.
E questa è stata
una tecnologia rivoluzionaria,
costosissima, ancora, come i cellulari
di allora degli anni ’80,
ma una tecnologia
che ha cambiato ancora una volta
il modo con cui i trapianti
venivano implementati
e per la prima volta si poteva parlare
di terapie a base di cellule
per la cura in questo caso della leucemia.
Ma la telefonia è andata avanti
nella sua rivoluzione
e questa immagine, che vi mostro oggi,
è stato il mio primo cellulare.
Era il 1998,
la tecnologia dei cellulari
si è trasferita da analogico a digitale
e tutti ci ricordiamo,
con grande emozione devo dire,
la possibilità di mandare dei messaggini,
cosa che adesso ci sembra
totalmente obsoleta,
ma allora era rivoluzionaria.
E cosa è successo a questi cellulari?
Sono diventati piccoli,
sono diventati...
hanno una grande autonomia.
Sono diventati sicuri,
possiamo telefonare senza grossi problemi.
Questa digitalizzazione della telefonia
ha cambiato radicalmente
il modo con cui noi comunichiamo,
ma in realtà la digitalizzazione
è avvenuta anche nelle terapie cellulari.
La capacità di identificare segnali 01,
cioè di discriminare tra una popolazione
cellulare e un’altra
ha consentito, diciamo
tra la fine degli anni ’90 e il 2000,
un po’ come la tecnologia GSM,
di selezionare, sulla base
di questo segnale 01, delle popolazioni
che chiamiamo linfociti,
ma che sono le stesse popolazioni
che aveva isolato
il nostro Maximow nel 1915
e che adesso possiamo manipolare,
possiamo selezionare
con un macchinario
che si chiama macchina da aferesi
e possiamo infondere nel paziente.
Questa non è altro che una
miniaturizzazione dei primi trapianti.
Non è altro che una digitalizzazione
dei primi trapianti
che sono stati implementati nell’uomo.
Ma questo certamente è rivoluzionario,
ma le sorprese non sono finite qua,
sia per la telefonia,
ma anche per i trapianti di cellule,
perché la cosa che ha sorpreso
personalmente
è quando è arrivata la tecnologia 3G.
Credo che abbia sorpreso
immagino tutti voi,
perché in un attrezzo di queste dimensioni
potevamo in realtà fare moltissime cose.
È arrivata la multimedialità,
è arrivata la capacità
di comunicare con il mondo
essendo in posti, in luoghi remoti.
Questa generazione di cellulari 3G,
in realtà,
ha come prerogativa la capacità
di condensare in poco il molto,
la capacità di avere delle app
che ci consentono di fare cose
che erano impensabili.
Ma la possibilità,
pensate alla possibilità
di aggiungere delle app a delle cellule
è una cosa impensabile, eppure è accaduto.
E questa è quella che io ho chiamato
scherzosamente la terapia 3G genica,
cioè cosa possiamo fare ad oggi
e cosa potremo fare di più
con le cellule?
Possiamo dare alle cellule delle app
che sostanzialmente
consentono alle cellule
di fare cose che non avrebbero
mai potuto fare.
Si chiama terapia genica,
ovvero noi possiamo prendere
quegli stessi linfociti,
quelle stesse cellule del paziente,
le possiamo portare in laboratorio
le carichiamo di app,
diamo a loro funzioni
che non avevano mai pensato di avere.
E poi le possiamo ritrapiantare
nel paziente.
Questa cosa è stata rivoluzionaria,
ha consentito la cura
di patologie congenite,
immunodeficienze, i tumori,
forme come la talassemia,
ed è sostanzialmente molto simile
alla possibilità di inserire
all’interno di un dispositivo elettronico
come un cellulare
tutto quello che oggi
per noi è in realtà routine.
Ma non è finita qui.
Oggi abbiamo la tecnologia 4G
nei cellulari.
Ma devo dire che non mi sono
accorto di averla,
se non che mio figlio
utilizza il mio cellulare
per vedersi in streaming
qualsiasi cosa.
Ma cosa ho capito?
Ho capito che in realtà la rivoluzione è
di riuscire a vedere ad alta velocità,
con una batteria infinita sostanzialmente,
se la confrontiamo
rispetto a quella degli anni ’80,
dei film ad alta definizione.
E voi dite: sì questo è un vezzo.
Sì è un vezzo,
ma è estremamente importante
se noi volessimo vedere un film,
ma è importante per una comunicazione
anche professionale,
per una comunicazione che riguarda
anche la scienza medica.
Allora la domanda che mi sono posto è:
ma è avvenuta la rivoluzione 4G
nelle terapie cellulari?
In realtà ce l’avevamo,
ce l’avevo sotto gli occhi,
ce l’abbiamo già in mano.
E vi faccio vedere questo,
che è un po’, in realtà, quello
che anche noi facciamo in laboratorio.
La tecnologia 4G consente di vedere
ad alta definizione film,
ma in realtà noi
stiamo producendo dei linfociti
che hanno la capacità
di vedere ad alta definizione cosa:
ad alta definizione i tumori
che sono il nostro target principale.
Quindi sostanzialmente noi possiamo
prendere le cellule del paziente,
portarle in laboratorio, modificare
e dare una tecnologia HD
per far vedere ai linfociti il tumore
con altissima definizione.
Vi annoio con qualche immagine
di laboratorio:
nella striscia in alto
vedete dei tumori colorati di rosso,
nella striscia intermedia vedete
dei tumori trattati
con dei linfociti non HD,
nell’ultima striscia
vedete dei linfociti HD.
Questi linfociti HD vedono così bene
il tumore che lo circondano,
le cellule verdi,
si amplificano
e lo uccidono nell’arco di 96 ore.
Quindi siamo già di fronte
a una rivoluzione 4G.
Ovviamente questo aspetto
è un aspetto importante,
ma che sta avendo già
un’ulteriore evoluzione
che non è altro che l’evoluzione 5G
che noi stiamo vedendo nei cellulari.
Devo dirvi che non ho ancora
completato bene,
appreso bene cosa vorrà dire avere il 5G,
ma quello che ho compreso è
che avremo dispositivi velocissimi,
dispositivi in grado di consentire
comunicazioni macchina-macchina,
dispositivi molto sicuri.
Queste tre cose saranno di estrema utilità
per la nostra salute,
per la salute dell’uomo
e questo sarà rivoluzionario
non solo dal punto di vista
della robotica, della medicina robotica,
ma anche della cura
tradizionale dei pazienti.
La rivoluzione 5G, signori,
c’è anche nelle terapie cellulari,
perché abbiamo in realtà
la possibilità di rendere
quelle cellule, di cui vi avevo parlato
prima, delle cellule utili per molti,
cellule universali.
E come possiamo fare?
Possiamo modificarne la loro faccia
per renderle invisibili al sistema immune,
per rendere una cellula, la mia cellula,
utile per tutti voi
o la sua cellula utile per tutti voi,
cioè rendere,
come la tecnologia 5G
è una tecnologia universale,
rendere le cellule
come un prodotto universale,
con un grande vantaggio tecnologico:
potremo, e questo è già in essere,
modificare queste cellule
nell’arco di 24 ore
e quindi rendere
un prodotto estremamente utile.
Quindi io concludo per dire,
come spero abbiate colto,
questo parallelo è servito a me
come percorso interno
per capire come stiamo andando,
in che direzione stiamo andando.
Ma la cosa più importante è
che man mano che il progresso
e l’innovazione aumentano
ed entrano nella nostra quotidianità
potremo avere in poco molto
e questo è quello che noi vogliamo fare
quando trattiamo i pazienti
con terapie cellulari.
Grazie.